a groom asked his wife for a divorce  while she was still wearing her wedding  dress nearly right after exchanging vows  the bride and groom were from a town  called Medina they had never met in  person which is not uncommon for people  marrying in some parts of the Middle  East in Saudi Customs a man and woman  are permitted to look at each other only  once before their wedding this couple  opted not to even take that first glance  the wedding took place without issue the  trouble began when the couple had to  pose for a photographer that's when the  bride removed her veil and smiled and  the groom did not like what he saw Lewis  and said you are not the girl I want to  marry you were not the one I had  imagined I am sorry but I divorce you  the bride had a total breakdown and had  to be taken to a hospital